heute vor zwei jahren starb die
boxlegende graciano rocchigiani nachdem
er auf sizilien von einem smart erfasst
und später an seinen verletzungen starb
in wenigen minuten soll nun seine
grabstätte enthüllt werden und genau um
dieses grab gibt es weiter streit in
seiner familie
bruder ralf und rockies tochter giannina
haben unterschiedliche ideen wie diese
aussehen sollte letztlich hat sich
janina als nächste verwandten
durchgesetzt sein bruder ralf wollte ein
etwas schlichtere version und vor ort
ist jetzt mein kollege jörg lubrich was
genau passiert dort heute also nach all
diesen familienstreit also heute am
zweiten todestag von graciano
rocchigiani wird eine würdige grabstätte
übergeben der öffentlichkeit übergeben
graziano ist vor zwei jahren ja
bekanntlich bei einem autounfall in
italien ums leben gekommen und dank
großer mithilfe der ex frau christine
rocchigiani und der tochter giannina ist
dieses werk entstanden von einer
berliner steinmetzfirma der berliner
steinmetz charakter hat es mit seinem
team geschaffen und den wenigen minuten
wird das ganze angst haben wir hier auf
den alten st matthäus kirchhof in
schöneberg einen der ältesten berlins wo
schon die gebrüder grimm begraben sind
oder rudolf virchow auch seine letzte
ruhe gefunden hat hier der
öffentlichkeit übergeben und graziano
ein würdiges denkmal gesetzt werden
ich übergebe jetzt an die akteure zur
feierlichen übergabe des angst hampels
steinmetz kagerer und toni krieglstein
sein mitarbeiter enthüllen jetzt das
grab
in form eines boxrings ein boxring
symbolisieren tauss roten tauen
wetterbeständig inmitten ein kleiner
granitstein unbeugsam aber herrlich
steht da drauf
janina hat jetzt das denkmal den
grabstein enthüllt ein berliner
musikstudent anton schneider spielt
songs der beatles und bon jovi
in liebevoller erinnerung an unseren
weltmeister wie auf dem grabstein mit
blattgold eingemeißelt steht darunter
seine größten erfolge weltmeistertitel
1988 der europameistertitel 91 und der
wm sieg 1998
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren